5:30 in the afternoon, in the food court at a table near Sbarro's, Nick and Cheyenne and Natalie are just hanging around killing time, waiting to go to a movie when their buddy Chase shows up and explains the Sydney situation.
下午5点半，在美食广场萨巴罗餐厅附近的一张桌子旁，尼克、夏恩和娜塔莉正无所事事地打发时间，等着去看电影，这时他们的朋友蔡斯出现了，并解释了悉尼那边的情况。
Sydney is my friend at the mall who ditched me for her boyfriend.
悉尼是我在商场认识的朋友，她为了男朋友把我抛弃了。
Chase had come to the mall with Sydney. But now he was here in the food court and she was with the boyfriend.
蔡斯是和悉尼一起来商场的。但现在他一个人在美食广场，而她正和男朋友在一起。
In American Eagle with her boyfriend. With her boyfriend buying another girl a present.
在美鹰傲博店和她男朋友在一起。和她男朋友一起给另一个女孩买礼物。
Uh oh.
噢，糟糕。
Her boyfriend has a lot of best girlfriends. And so he's getting like two other girls' presents while he's with his girlfriend. But he came to the mall with another girl and met up with his girlfriend.
她男朋友有很多红颜知己。所以他在陪女朋友的时候，还要顺便给另外两个女孩买礼物。但他其实是和另一个女孩一起来商场，然后才碰见他女朋友的。
What does she think about this?
她对此怎么看？
She just doesn't care anymore because it's been going on for too long.
她已经不在乎了，因为这种情况已经持续太久了。
And do you like her?
你喜欢她吗？
I do not. I like another girl named Courtney.
我不喜欢。我喜欢另一个叫考特尼的女孩。
This is your ex-girlfriend.
这是你的前女友。
My ex-girlfriend. We dated for nine months and she broke up with me.
我的前女友。我们交往了九个月，然后她跟我分手了。
Chase is at the mall about once a week and there's always a danger that he's going to run into Courtney since they used to come here together. But he's only seen her here once. It was right in the food court. Right near where we're sitting. It wasn't pleasant.
蔡斯大约每周来一次商场，他总是担心会碰到考特尼，因为他们以前常一起来这里。但他只在这里见过她一次。就在美食广场。就在我们坐的这附近。那次见面很不愉快。
She was with her entire cheerleading squad. They were all in uniform. Because they were doing a fundraiser car wash or something.
当时她和整个啦啦队在一起。她们都穿着制服。因为她们在搞洗车募捐活动之类的。
They were definitely talking. You know, walked by, looked back. Oh my gosh, I just saw him.
她们肯定在谈论我。你知道的，走过去，又回头看。天哪，我刚才看到他了。
Like any Friday afternoon after school, lots of teenagers are in the mall today. Halfway across the food court, two high school sophomores named Colton and Chris wave to some kids at the Dairy Queen.
就像放学后的任何一个周五下午一样，今天商场里有很多青少年。在美食广场的另一头，两个名叫科尔顿和克里斯的高二学生向冰雪皇后餐厅那边的一些孩子挥手。
Those are our friends. Those are our friends.
那是我们的朋友。那是我们的朋友。
Where?
在哪里？
That's Danielle, the one in the brown. That's Lindsay and that's one of my friend's Deven. They go to my school. I met a new person today, her name's Rachel. I didn't even know her. I walked up to her and asked her if she wanted to hang out.
那是丹妮尔，穿棕色衣服的那个。那是琳赛，还有那是我的一个朋友德文。他们和我上同一所学校。我今天认识了一个新朋友，她叫瑞秋。我以前根本不认识她。我直接走过去问她想不想一起玩。
I was walking back to the food court to get some lunch and I accidentally bumped my shoulder into her. And I said I'm sorry. Excuse me. And then she said, no, it's OK. And I asked her name and her age. And she actually goes to my school and I've never seen her before. Actually, she had lunch with me, so that was a plus.
我当时正走回美食广场去吃午饭，不小心撞到了她的肩膀。我说对不起，借过。然后她说，没关系。我就问了她的名字和年龄。原来她和我上同一所学校，但我以前从没见过她。事实上，她还陪我一起吃了午饭，这真是个意外收获。
We came to the mall to see what was happening there at Christmas. When there are stories on Radio TV about the world of shopping, it's pretty much always about how much shopping we're all doing.
我们来商场是为了看看圣诞节期间这里的情况。当广播或电视节目报道购物世界时，内容几乎总是在讲我们大家消费了多少。
Were this year's Thanksgiving purchases as much as last year's? What does that say about the economy? That kind of thing. But it doesn't really tell you what it feels like for the people who work at a big retail operation, like this mall right now. Or for the people who hang out at the mall. Because the mall's much more than just sales.
今年的感恩节购物额比去年多吗？这对经济意味着什么？诸如此类的话题。但这些报道并没有真正告诉你，在像现在这家商场这样的大型零售机构里工作的人，或者那些在商场闲逛的人，感受是怎样的。因为商场不仅仅是买卖东西的地方。
This is just a place like if you're having troubles with family, or if you just want to have somewhere to hang out. You know, the movies is somewhere, but this place calms me down more.
这就像是一个地方，如果你有家庭烦恼，或者你只是想找个地方待着。你知道，电影院是一个去处，但这个地方让我更冷静。
And what about you, is it the same for you? Like this is a place where you can get out of the house?
那你呢，对你来说也是一样吗？这也是一个让你逃离家庭的地方？
Yeah, same thing. Get away from my brother.
是的，一样。为了躲开我哥哥。
And why do you want to get away from your brother?
你为什么要躲开你哥哥？
Because he's like a bully. He hits me and calls me names.
因为他像个恶霸。他打我，还骂我。
And there's nothing you can do about it?
你对此无能为力吗？
Nope. Because if I try to hit him, he'll hit me back even harder.
没办法。因为如果我试着反击，他会打得更狠。
So does it work coming here?
那来这里有用吗？
Yeah. Gets away for a few hours. Then go back home and everything's back to normal. Everything just calms down.
有。可以躲几个小时。然后回家，一切又恢复正常了。一切都会平静下来。
The name of this particular mall is the Cool Springs Galleria, outside Nashville. It's not the fanciest mall in the area. When we visited there was no Tiffany store or Burberry or Apple Store. But it was newly redone with big, cushy chairs everywhere, and a play area for toddlers, and all the regular Abercrombie, Aeropostale, Williams-Sonoma stores that you'd expect in a nice mall. Five department stores: Macy's, Dillard's, Belk, JCPenney and Sears. It's the kind of upscale leaning, but not snooty mall that if you needed to shoot a mall scene for a new Miley Cyrus movie, you might do it here. In fact, she did. 150 shops, 6,500 parking spaces.
这家商场叫酷泉广场，位于纳什维尔郊外。它不是该地区最豪华的商场。我们去的时候，那里没有蒂芙尼、博柏利或苹果商店。但它刚刚翻新过，到处都是舒适的大椅子，还有一个幼儿游乐区，以及你在高档商场里期望看到的所有常规品牌，比如Abercrombie、Aeropostale、Williams-Sonoma。有五家百货公司：梅西百货、迪拉德百货、贝尔百货、杰西潘尼和西尔斯。这是一种偏高档但又不傲慢的商场，如果你需要为新的麦莉·赛勒斯电影拍摄商场场景，你可能会选这里。事实上，她确实在这里拍过。这里有150家商店，6500个停车位。
We were here at this time of year, mid December, exactly two weeks before Christmas two years ago in 2008. It was me and my fellow producers, Nancy Updike and Wendy  Dorr. Today on our show we bring you, Scenes From a Mall. Stories of people we met and what we saw. And we'll leave this Nashville mall just once this hour for a story about a Christmas related political fight in an organization of professional Santas. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
我们在两年前的这个时候，也就是2008年圣诞节前两周，来到了这里。当时我和我的制片人同事南希·厄普代克和温迪·多尔一起。今天的节目我们要带给大家的是《商场片段》。我们将讲述我们遇到的人和我们看到的事。在这一小时里，我们将暂时离开这家纳什维尔的商场，去讲一个关于专业圣诞老人组织中与圣诞节相关的政治斗争的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。请继续收听。
"Act one, Love Line."
“第一幕，爱情专线。”
Let's begin our tour of life at to the mall here.
让我们从这里开始我们的商场生活之旅。
How did you guys meet?
你们是怎么认识的？
Here, actually, at the mall.
就在这儿，其实是在商场里。
I actually tried to sell her a phone. And she just kind of walked by one day and I tried to stop her and tried to sell her a phone and she just kind of stayed there since.
当时我试图向她推销手机。有一天她正好路过，我试着拦住她推销手机，从那以后她就赖在这儿了。
He was charming, but after the second date it kind of wore off a little bit. He is a great guy though, I'll say that.
他当时很有魅力，但第二次约会后，那种感觉就消退了一些。不过我必须说，他是个好人。
Russell and Chandler are engaged. I met them at the T-Mobile kiosk on the lower level of the mall, where Russell is the number one salesman. When I wandered up and started talking to him, it was late in the day and it was just him and a co-worker, no Chandler.
罗素和钱德勒已经订婚了。我是在商场下层的T-Mobile亭位遇到他们的，罗素是那里的头号销售员。我溜达到那里开始和他聊天时，天色已晚，当时只有他和一位同事在，钱德勒不在。
Russell was explaining to me that it's hard selling T-Mobile in this mall because we were in Franklin County. And Franklin County is Verizon country.
罗素向我解释说，在这个商场里推销T-Mobile很难，因为我们在富兰克林县。而富兰克林县是Verizon的地盘。
Yeah, like people will come up here and be like, you know, do you know where Verizon is? And it's like, would you go into Brookstone and ask where-- Sharper Image. Would you go ask them where that is? You wouldn't do that. It just disrespectful. People feel like since Verizon is more expensive, it's better. I will tell people they can save money and they're like, but I don't care.
是的，人们会走过来问，你知道Verizon在哪里吗？这就像，你会走进Brookstone问Sharper Image在哪里吗？你会那样做吗？这简直不礼貌。人们觉得因为Verizon更贵，所以它更好。我告诉人们他们可以省钱，他们却说，我不在乎。
It's galling to Russell. Because he truly believes in T-Mobile. When he talks to me about the pros and cons of his arch-rival, Verizon, and starts to lay out the facts about price and especially customer service, and how T-Mobile is the better deal, I do not feel like he's selling me. Somehow it feels like he is sharing a basic truth about the world that he has discovered and just needs to get across.
这让罗素感到气愤。因为他真心相信T-Mobile。当他向我谈论他死对头Verizon的优缺点，并开始列举价格和客户服务方面的事实，以及T-Mobile为何更划算时，我并没有感到他在向我推销。不知为何，感觉他是在分享他发现的关于这个世界的一个基本真理，并且迫切需要传达出来。
He has this air of unslick sincerity to him, like he's somebody who geeked out on cellphones and knows everything, and can give you the wisdom of this nerdy obsession of his. And that is obviously a big reason that he's the number one salesman here. And when he described how he ended up in this mall, I realized, I was just the latest in a series of people who saw this quality in him.
他身上有一种不虚伪的真诚，就像那种对手机着迷并无所不知的人，能给你这种书呆子式执着的智慧。很显然，这就是他是这里头号销售员的一个重要原因。当他描述自己是如何来到这个商场时，我意识到，我只是他那一系列发现这种特质的人中的最新一个。
He'd been working construction and that a guy trying to sell him a phone offered him a job. Then he was secret shopped by a rival T-Mobile store who poached him away from that first store. And then he was poached from that store by his current boss. All this happened in a year. He's just 19.
他原本在做建筑工，后来一个试图向他推销手机的人给了他一份工作。接着，一家竞争对手的T-Mobile门店对他进行了秘密购物评估，并从第一家店把他挖走了。随后，他现在的老板又把他从那家店挖了过来。这一切都发生在一年的时间里。他才19岁。
And compare the money you made in construction with the money you make at T-Mobile.
把你在建筑行业赚的钱和你在T-Mobile赚的钱比较一下。
Oh my gosh. I mean, I make less per day as far as hourly goes. But I mean, the T-Mobile, not only do I get health benefits, 401(k), but target commission for a sales rep is $14,000 a year. Say I'm better than anybody else, so I can do $20,000. So that's $40,000 right there before taxes. So that's a lot of money.
天哪。我是说，按时薪算，我每天赚得更少。但T-Mobile不仅提供健康福利、401(k)退休金，而且销售代表的目标佣金是每年14,000美元。假设我比别人做得好，我能拿到20,000美元。扣税前这就是40,000美元。所以这笔钱很多。
How long do you think you'll stay in phones?
你觉得你会做手机行业多久？
I don't know, probably like five years. Probably till we get out of this recession that we're in right now. Unless another opportunity comes. I don't want to be a company man. I want to be an entrepreneur and own my own business. Because I think that's the only real way to get rich. I don't want to live that lifestyle where it's from paycheck to paycheck.
不知道，大概五年吧。可能直到我们走出目前的经济衰退。除非有其他机会。我不想当个安分守己的员工。我想成为一名企业家，拥有自己的企业。因为我觉得那是致富的唯一途径。我不想过那种月光族的生活。
Is that how you grew up, you family was just paycheck to paycheck?
你是在那样的环境中长大的吗，你的家人也是月光族？
Yeah. And I just don't want to be like that. So I feel like I'm already in a better position to be 19 and pretty much making the same money their making.
是的。我不想变成那样。所以我感觉自己在19岁时就已经处在更好的位置，赚的钱和他们差不多。
What do they say about that?
他们对此怎么说？
Oh, nothing. I hardly ever talk to my dad and my mom, I mean, my mom-- I'm 19. My mom's married to a guy that's 24. We don't really hang out or talk that much.
噢，没什么。我几乎不和我爸妈交流，我是说，我妈……我19岁了。我妈嫁给了一个24岁的男人。我们真的不怎么聚在一起，也不怎么聊天。
So while Russell's explaining all this, his finance Chandler strolls up to the T-Mobile booth. They don't talk, but he keeps getting text messages-- mid-interview. Till finally--
所以，在罗素解释这一切的时候，他的未婚妻钱德勒溜达到T-Mobile展位。他们没说话，但他一直在收到短信——就在采访中间。直到最后——
You know, all they've got to do--
你知道，他们所要做的就是——
Who's texting you?
谁在给你发短信？
My fiance.
我的未婚妻。
She's standing right there.
她就站在那儿。
I know.
我知道。
What did you say?
你刚才说什么？
Can you jump in on the mike?
你能对着麦克风说吗？
What do you do?
你是做什么的？
I actually work at Sonic.
我其实在Sonic工作。
Sonic, the hamburger stand?
Sonic，那个汉堡摊？
The hamburger stand. The Sonic Drive-In, the ultimate drink stop.
那个汉堡摊。Sonic免下车餐厅，终极饮品站。
OK, I'm just going to cut in here and say, have you noticed she is selling. Because she is not just a waitress at the ultimate drink stop, she is the number one earner at the ultimate drink stop. She makes more money than the number one T-Mobile salesman, her fiance, Russell.
好的，我得插一句，你注意到她在推销了吗？因为她不仅是终极饮品站的服务员，她还是那里的头号创收者。她赚的钱比头号T-Mobile销售员，也就是她的未婚夫罗素还要多。
Do you confirm this?
你证实这一点吗？
Yeah, she does. It's like the tip money. I mean, the thing is she works in a small town and so she gets a lot of the same people that eat there every day. And she remembers all the people and remembers what they order. So they tip her more because they know her. And she's the only one that skates and she looks the best.
是的，确实如此。就像是小费收入。问题是她在小镇工作，所以她每天都遇到很多回头客。她记得所有人，也记得他们点什么。所以他们给她的小费更多，因为他们认识她。而且她是唯一穿旱冰鞋溜冰的，她看起来最棒。
The thing about the roller skates is, it's faster. So you take out more food, so you make more money. And people like it. It's old fashioned, people don't do it anymore. It is a little complicated. It's skating on concrete that's not meant to be skated on. You got a cup carrier in one hand and trying to carry all this food.
穿旱冰鞋的好处是，速度更快。所以你可以送出更多的食物，赚更多的钱。人们也喜欢这样。这是老派做法，现在没人这么做了。这其实有点复杂。要在本来不是为滑冰设计的混凝土路面上滑。手里拿着杯托，还得试图端着这些食物。
And so of the two of you, who's the better salesperson?
那么你们两个中，谁是更好的销售员？
Definitely me.
绝对是我。
What do you say on that?
你对此有什么看法？
She's more persuasive. I'm the better salesman, but she's very persuasive in talking to people.
她更具说服力。我是更好的销售员，但她在和人交谈时非常有说服力。
This is the kind of logic that helps people stay together for the rest of their lives. Like Russell, Chandler is estranged from her family. She got a job and took night classes so she could graduate from high school at 16 and move out.
这种逻辑有助于人们长久地在一起。像罗素一样，钱德勒也和家人疏远了。她找了工作，上夜校，好让自己在16岁时从高中毕业并搬出去住。
Now she's just 18. She and Russell live together. They just got a new puppy. Russell doesn't want to go to college. He doesn't see the point. He works with guys who went to college and he makes more than they do. But Chandler wants college.
现在她才18岁。她和罗素住在一起。他们刚养了一只小狗。罗素不想上大学。他看不出上大学的意义。他一起工作的那些人上过大学，但他赚得比他们多。但钱德勒想上大学。
I really want to, but it's not the right time because I don't have the money and I don't like loans at all. I don't like being in debt. I don't like owing money. That's where my family's gotten in a lot of trouble, and that's the position that they're in right now.
我真的很想，但现在不是时候，因为我没钱，而且我非常讨厌贷款。我不喜欢负债。我不喜欢欠钱。我的家人就是在这一点上陷入了很大的麻烦，他们现在就是处于这种境地。
So she and Russell are making this future together. She wants to be a nurse. Actually, she wants to be a dermatologist, but that's going to take too long and cost too much. So she's going for nurse. He wants to convert the world to T-Mobile.
所以她和罗素正在一起创造这个未来。她想当护士。其实，她想当皮肤科医生，但那需要太久，成本太高。所以她打算先做护士。他想把全世界都转换到T-Mobile。
Chandler signed up with Russell long before she signed up with T-Mobile, which is kind of a sore point with him. But Russell being Russell, he did not give up. There was a sale to make. He needed her to admit and enjoy the superiority of T-Mobile.
钱德勒签约T-Mobile的时间比她跟罗素在一起的时间要晚得多，这对罗素来说是个痛点。但罗素就是罗素，他没有放弃。有一个订单要完成。他需要她承认并享受T-Mobile的优越性。
I asked Chandler how many dates she went on with Russell before he stopped trying to sell her a phone. And she sighs in this way that it's clear that it went on way too long. Here, let me play you that tape.
我问钱德勒在罗素放弃向她推销手机之前，他们约会了多少次。她叹了口气，很明显那持续得太久了。来，我放那段录音给你听。
How many dates had you been on when he stopped trying to sell you the phone?
在他不再试图向你推销手机之前，你们约会了多少次？
Oh.
噢。
Once she got T-Mobile I stopped trying to sell her the phone. But the only way I could get her to get T-Mobile is if I added a line on my plan and gave it to her. So that's what it took to get her to go to T-Mobile.
一旦她用了T-Mobile，我就不再试图向她推销手机了。但我让她使用T-Mobile的唯一方法就是我在我的套餐里增加一条线路并给给她用。这就是让她转用T-Mobile所付出的代价。
Because what was she before?
因为她以前用的是什么？
AT&T.
AT&T。
AT&T, the indignity. Chandler sighs and she says, no, no. She really likes T-Mobile a lot. It's really better. Sometimes she has some problems, but T-Mobile is great. Customer service, she says, out of the roof. It's really, really good.
AT&T，真是耻辱。钱德勒叹了口气说，不，不。她真的很喜欢T-Mobile。它确实更好。有时会有一些小问题，但T-Mobile很棒。她说客户服务好得惊人。真的非常非常棒。
"Act two, Not Dead Yet."
“第二幕，还没死透。”
Back in the food court I ran into three eighth graders, best friends, who say they come here once a week for maybe four hours at a time.
回到美食广场，我遇到了三名八年级的学生，她们是最好的朋友，说她们每周会来这里一次，每次待大约四个小时。
Well, we get in. We normally try on the ugliest dresses we can find.
嗯，我们进来。我们通常试穿我们能找到的最丑的裙子。
Yeah, prom section.
是的，舞会服装区。
Yeah, the prom section.
Describe the ugliest one you saw today.
描述一下你今天看到的最丑的一件。
It was like really, really tight and it has ruches on it and tons of sparkles. All three of us.
它非常非常紧，上面有很多褶皱和成吨的亮片。我们三个都试了。
All three of us. We all tried on it on.
我们三个都试了。
We all tried it on.
我们都试穿了。
Has the recession affected the three of you?
经济衰退对你们三个有影响吗？
What? The recession?
什么？经济衰退？
What's recession mean?
经济衰退是什么意思？
That's a big word. We're not the smartest people here.
那是个大词。我们不是这里最聪明的人。
14, not 40.
14岁，不是40岁。
This of course, was a minority view. Most people at the mall had heard of the recession.
当然，这只是少数人的看法。商场里的大多数人都听说过经济衰退。
Two years ago this week, December 2008 when we were recording, it was near the beginning of the current recession we're in. The stores here were still doing a lot of business by putting huge amounts of stuff on sale. You still see that strategy this year. And a handful of stores actually had business increasing during the hard economic times. Like the Chick-fil-A in the food court at Cool Springs. Business was up 10% since the beginning of November said the franchise's owner, Jeannie [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
两年前的这一周，2008年12月我们录音的时候，正处于我们现在经历的经济衰退的初期。这里的商店通过将大量商品打折促销，依然在进行大量的业务。你今年依然能看到这种策略。而且在经济困难时期，确实有少数商店的业务在增长。比如酷泉商场美食广场的Chick-fil-A。特许经营店老板珍妮说，自11月初以来，业务增长了10%。
All right, Chick-fil-A sandwich, no pickle. But then she wants a side of pickles.
好的，Chick-fil-A三明治，不要酸黄瓜。但她想要一份额外的酸黄瓜。
Jeannie gets behind the register when the lines get long. She has a successful small business owner's brisk creativity. When a harried young mom starts rooting around in her purse in frustration looking for her coupon, Jeannie goes over and fishes in the trash for one.
当排队变长时，珍妮会亲自去收银台。她有一种成功的个体户那样的敏锐创造力。当一位忙乱的年轻妈妈在包里翻找优惠券感到沮丧时，珍妮会走过去从垃圾桶里找出一张来。
Is it the little long one?
是那张细长的吗？
No, it's this one.
不，是这张。
She finds the coupon, washes her hands, and gets back to doling out chicken, soda, and courtesy. She calls every male customer sir. Even the teenage boys in braces ordering strawberry milk shakes.
她找到优惠券，洗了洗手，又回去分发炸鸡、苏打水和礼貌服务。她称呼每一位男性顾客为“先生”。即使是那些戴着牙套、点草莓奶昔的十几岁男孩。
$10.49 sir. I'll have your shake coming right up.
10.49美元，先生。奶昔马上就好。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Chick-fil-A franchise owners are responsible for their own advertising and marketing. And so Jeannie just paid for a Chick-fil-A sign in the mall elevator, which she says has  boosted customers. And when the rush slows down, Jeannie walks the mall.
Chick-fil-A特许经营店主负责自己的广告和营销。所以珍妮刚为商场电梯里的Chick-fil-A标志付了费，她说这增加了客源。当人流变慢时，珍妮就会在商场里走动。
Just seeing what's going on in the mall, seeing how the stores look. Kind of getting to know all the managers. I want to know everybody in the mall. If I can I want to be the mayor of the mall. You know, I want to know everybody.
看看商场里发生了什么，看看商店看起来怎么样。顺便认识所有的经理。我想认识商场里的每一个人。如果可以，我想成为商场的市长。你知道，我想认识所有人。
Jeannie is definitely mayoral as she walks around, welcoming newcomers.
珍妮在四处走动时确实像市长一样，欢迎新来的人。
I didn't know you guys were here. How long have you been here?
我不知道你们在这儿。你们在这儿多久了？
Poking around in stores.
在商店里逛逛。
We're checking out your sales. A lot of good stuff.
我们正在看你们的打折活动。有很多好东西。
Teasing people.
逗逗人。
What you got. You getting married?
你得到了什么。你要结婚了吗？
And always cheerfully plotting how to bring in more customers. In that way, her business really is like running for mayor. Political candidates talk about how important it is to reach out to voters again and again, in different ways, never let them forget you. Especially your base, which for Jeannie is the people who work in the mall. People who work in the mall make up 50% of her business.
总是乐呵呵地策划如何吸引更多顾客。从某种意义上说，她经营生意确实像是在竞选市长。政治候选人谈论不断地以各种方式接触选民是多么重要，永远不要让他们忘记你。尤其是你的基础群体，对珍妮来说，就是那些在商场工作的人。在商场工作的人占了她生意的一半。
The other day, Jeannie sent one of her employees to walk around inside the mall dressed in a cow suit. The cow is Chick-fil-A's mascot. His tagline is, "Eat more chicken." And that cow had his picture taken with employees at every store and every kiosk in the mall.
前几天，珍妮派了一名员工穿着奶牛服在商场里走动。那头奶牛是Chick-fil-A的吉祥物。他的口号是“多吃鸡肉”。那头奶牛和商场里每一家店、每一个亭位的员工合了影。
And then when we delivered the picture back to them, so we've actually touched them two times. When we took the cow there and they got to know the cow and got their picture made, that was one time. Then when we delivered the picture that was another time. So it's just constantly keeping in touch with these people, being friendly with them, staying connected, and that's what keeps our business going.
然后当我们把照片送回给他们时，我们实际上已经两次接触他们了。我们带着奶牛去那里，他们认识了奶牛并拍了照，那是一次。然后我们把照片送过去，那是另一次。所以就是不断地与这些人保持联系，对他们友好，保持连接，这就是让我们生意持续下去的原因。
Jeannie's message, there's nothing in this economy stopping you from eating a chicken sandwich. I think a lot of store owners are feeling some version of that feeling.
珍妮的信息是：在这个经济环境下，没有任何东西能阻止你吃一个鸡肉三明治。我想很多店主都有某种类似的感受。
I was shopping last week for a Christmas present trying to decide between two things. The store owner says to me, you still have a job. Yeah, a huge percentage of the country is unemployed, but nothing has changed for you. Why can't you act like it?
我上周去买圣诞礼物，试图在两样东西之间做决定。店主对我说，你还有工作。是的，这个国家有很大比例的人失业了，但你什么都没变。你为什么不能表现得像那样呢？
And not every store is surviving. Here at Cool Springs one of the stores that was about to close when we visited was Carlton Cards up on the second floor. There weren't any big signs announcing it or anything. In fact, it was kind of a weird thing to see. The store was like this cheerful, red toy box filled with fluffy little dolls and bracelets and Valentine's hearts. And then, scotch taped up with scotch tape here and there, these austere signs that the staff had printed on the store's computer on regular 8 and 1/2 by 11 paper declaring in all caps "50% OFF. STORE CLOSING. ALL SALES FINAL."
并不是每家商店都能生存下来。在酷泉商场，我们去的时候有一家即将倒闭的商店是位于二楼的Carlton Cards。没有任何大招牌宣布这件事或之类的。事实上，看到那个场景有点奇怪。那家店就像是一个快乐的红色玩具盒，装满了毛茸茸的小玩偶、手镯和情人节爱心。然后，零零散散地贴着胶带，贴着这些朴素的标志，这是员工在商店电脑上用普通的8.5乘11纸打印出来的，上面用全大写字母写着“5折。商店倒闭。所有商品最终清算。”
I'm just putting out old stock that we have in the back room. We're cleaning out and clearing out and put it on clearance.
我只是在把后屋的旧存货拿出来。我们正在清理并腾出空间，全部降价处理。
This woman preferred not to give her name. They were selling stuff from the stock room partly because the corporate office stopped sending them new product to put on the shelves back in early November. A couple weeks before they were told that the store would close.
这位女士不愿透露姓名。她们销售库存商品的部分原因是公司总部在11月初就停止给她们发新货了。在被告知商店要倒闭的前几周，她们就已经停止收到新产品了。
My boss kept telling me over and over again because we stopped getting shipments. She keep saying, oh, they did this to me before at the other store that we're going to close. And I'm like, no, we're fine. Our sales aren't down, or nothing's going on. You know, why would we-- sure enough, she was right.
我的老板一再告诉我，因为我们停止收到货物了。她一直说，噢，她们以前在另一家店倒闭前也这么对我。我说，不，我们很好。我们的销售额没有下降，没发生什么事。你知道，我们为什么要……果然，她是对的。
And so are they going to relocate you somewhere else?
所以她们会把你调到别的地方吗？
Not this store. Right now there's no openings for me, or my boss even. This store's just done.
这家店不会。现在没有适合我的职位，甚至没有适合我老板的。这家店彻底完了。
So what happens to you?
那你怎么办？
I try for something else. After 13 years I don't know what I'm going to do. I've been doing this since I was 20 years old and I have no idea. Husband's been cut in hours, family members have lost their jobs too, so I can't believe it really. Come down from Michigan where it was a dead state to come down here find jobs that are good and stuff. And then two years later, the same thing's happening.
我尝试找别的。做了13年，我不知道我要做什么。我从20岁就开始做这个，我毫无头绪。丈夫也被削减了工时，家庭成员也失业了，所以我简直不敢相信。从密歇根那个萧条的州下来，在这里找到好工作之类的。结果两年后，同样的事情又发生了。
What kind of business if your husband in?
你丈夫是做什么生意的？
He was a steel worker up in Michigan and then he came down here and started working for Penske, who supplied Saturn. And then when Saturn went out for them few months over there-- well, for the year and a half they were out over there, he lost his job from them. Now he's just working as whatever he can find.
他在密歇根是一名钢铁工人，后来他来到这里，开始为供应土星汽车的Penske公司工作。后来土星公司在那边停产了几个月——嗯，在那边停产的一年半里，他丢了工作。现在他只能找任何能找到的工作。
Is he finding manufacturing jobs?
他能找到制造业的工作吗？
No. He's right now doing forklift driving.
不。他现在在开叉车。
And is he making anything like the money he made when he moved here?
他赚的钱能和搬到这里时一样多吗？
Oh no. Just me. I came down with my salary down here. And now I'm out of that salary too. It's scary.
哦，不能。只有我。我是带着那份工资下来的。现在我也丢了那份工资。这很可怕。
You have kids?
你有孩子吗？
I don't. I don't know what I'd do then.
没有。我不知道如果有孩子我该怎么办。
What's the day the store closes?
商店倒闭的日子是哪天？
The 28. It's the last day of business.
28号。这是营业的最后一天。
And so how are things here in the store, like how are you guys doing?
那么店里的情况如何，你们感觉怎么样？
We're sad. We're sad and it gets stressful. And for everybody to keep coming up to you going, oh, you're closing? I got a good bargain, yackity-schmackity. Just forgetting the fact that a human don't have money now. Because you got half off. Where were you beforehand to buy it at full price and maybe save my job?
我们很伤心。我们很伤心，而且压力很大。每个人都走过来对你说，噢，你们要倒闭了？我捡了个大便宜，巴拉巴拉。完全忽略了一个人现在没钱的事实。因为你们半价了。你们之前都在哪儿？怎么没按原价买，那样也许就能救我的工作了？
So the customers are saying these things and then are you guys sad? What are you guys saying to each other? What are you able to do for each other?
所以顾客在说这些话，那么你们感到伤心吗？你们在对彼此说什么？你们能为彼此做些什么？
We try not to talk about it. That's it, plain and simple. I don't want to talk about it. I'm not ready to think about it yet. Not till maybe the 26. But at least this year you don't have to go through the returns and you don't have to go through-- you know.
我们尽量不谈论这件事。就是这样，简单明了。我不想谈论它。我还没准备好去想它。至少要到26号以后。但至少今年你不用处理退货了，也不用经历……你知道。
I noticed the sign, "All sales are final."
我注意到那个标志，“所有销售最终清算。”
Yep. That'll be nice. Just did my 13th year here and first Christmas Eve I'll get off. So hey, that's still not a bright enough lining, but I'll take it. This year.
是的。那会很好。刚在这里做完第13年，这是第一个我能休息的平安夜。所以嘿，那还不够亮堂，但我接受。今年。
Coming up, why Santa is mad at Santa. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，为什么圣诞老人对圣诞老人很生气。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际电台，我们的节目继续。
Well, it's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Scenes From a Mall, we've been bringing you stories recorded this month at a shopping mall, Cool Springs Galleria in Nashville.
好吧，这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《商场片段》，我们一直在讲述这个月在纳什维尔的酷泉广场购物中心录制的故事。
In addition to whatever happens at the North Pole, there is a Santa industry that springs up at malls all over the country every Christmas with photographers and helpers. You see Santa in parades. This year you see him at the White House. We're going to talk about the people in that business right now. Parents of small children, consider this fair notice. Decide if your child should be hearing about the side of Christmas. I'll wait. OK, only grownups left?
除了北极发生的一切，每年的圣诞节，全国各地的商场都会涌现出一个圣诞老人产业，包括摄影师和助手。你在游行中看到圣诞老人。今年你在白宫看到他。我们现在要谈谈这个行业里的人。小孩子的父母，请注意。决定一下你的孩子是否应该听到圣诞节的这一面。我等一会儿。好吧，只剩下大人了吗？
We saw a story in the Wall Street Journal about a rift in the world of professional Santas, a fight that turned Santa against Santa. Reporter Josh Bearman looked into it for us.
我们在《华尔街日报》上看到了一篇关于职业圣诞老人世界分裂的故事，一场让圣诞老人对抗圣诞老人的斗争。记者乔什·比尔曼为我们进行了调查。
This is a Christmas story, a tale of two Santas. On the one side is Tim Conaghan, a full-time professional Santa with a big belly and a real flowing white beard. Tim is so dedicated to the idea of Santa Claus, his house is in a perpetual state of Christmas. There are St. Nick tapestries, a workshop with a calendar marking the days until Christmas, and a grand throne where Santa Tim receives children. It is like the North Pole, if the North Pole were in Riverside, California.
这是一个圣诞故事，关于两个圣诞老人的传说。一边是蒂姆·科纳汉，一个拥有大肚子和真正飘逸白胡子的全职专业圣诞老人。蒂姆对圣诞老人的理念非常专注，他的家终年处于圣诞状态。到处是圣尼古拉斯的挂毯，一个带有标记圣诞倒计时的日历的工作坊，以及一个宏伟的王座，圣诞老人蒂姆在那里接待孩子们。这就像北极，如果北极在加利福尼亚州的里弗赛德的话。
As Santa Tim takes me on a tour, he is dressed in a sort of Santa casual. Red and white shirt and green pants dotted with candy canes. The Santa saturation here is such that as Santa Tim provides a lengthy detailed history on the image of Santa Claus and how best to achieve that authentic Santa look, there's still more Santa to come.
当圣诞老人蒂姆带我参观时，他穿着一种圣诞休闲装。红白相间的衬衫和点缀着拐杖糖的绿裤子。这里的圣诞氛围如此浓厚，以至于当圣诞老人蒂姆详细介绍圣诞老人形象的历史以及如何最好地实现那种正宗圣诞老人外观时，还有更多的圣诞内容要来。
A number 30 rouge for the cheeks and maybe a little touch on the nose to give him a little bit of weathered look. Forgot I got the clocks going too.
腮红30号，也许在鼻子上涂一点点，让他看起来有点风霜感。忘了我也开着时钟了。
No, that's fine. What's that song? What's the song?
不，没关系。那首歌是什么？那首歌是什么？
OK, the carols being sung by a choir. "Merry Christmas."
好的，合唱团正在唱颂歌。“圣诞快乐。”
The counterpart to Santa Tim is Santa Nick. That's right, his actual name is Nicholas. And he too has a belly and a real white beard, which means that he must always be prepared for Santa contingencies, even in July, even when he's out running an errand.
与圣诞老人蒂姆对应的是圣诞老人尼克。没错，他真名就叫尼古拉斯。他也有一个肚子和真正的白胡子，这意味着他必须时刻为圣诞老人的突发状况做好准备，即使在七月，即使在他出门办事的时候。
I went to my storage facility to pick up some stuff and I pulled in in my car with my wife and my two kids. And I hadn't even gotten out of the car yet and there was these two little girls. And the one little girl about five years old, she goes, hi, Santa.
我去我的仓库取东西，我和妻子以及两个孩子开车去了。我甚至还没下车，就有两个小女孩。其中一个大约五岁的小女孩说，嗨，圣诞老人。
I was dressed nothing at all like Santa Claus. Why I always carry a bag of little toys and stickers with me that I'm able to say, well, hello. How are you? And then I usually give them a little present. Talk to them for a little bit and say-- because the mother was gone and she told the child, leave that man alone. And I said, no, no. She's OK. She found out who I am.
我一点也不像圣诞老人。为什么我总是随身携带一袋小玩具和贴纸，这样我就能说，好吧，你好。你好吗？然后我通常会给她们一件小礼物。跟她们聊一会儿，然后说——因为她妈妈走开了，她告诉孩子，别管那个人。我说，不，不。她没关系。她发现我是谁了。
But the story of Santa Tim and Santa Nick is not like most Christmas parables. It is not about impoverished couples giving up their most cherished things to sacrifice for each other, or an avaricious curmudgeon finally learning to let love into his heart. This story is sort of the opposite in fact. It is a story about how these two men, Santa Tim and Santa Nick, so much alike, potential allies in a great cause, came instead to lead rival factions in the bitter Santa civil war. And came themselves to be arch enemies. Here's Nick talking about Tim.
但圣诞老人蒂姆和圣诞老人尼克的故事不像大多数圣诞寓言。它不是关于贫困夫妇为了对方牺牲自己最珍贵的东西，也不是关于一个贪婪的守财奴终于学会了让爱进入他的心。事实上，这个故事正好相反。这是一个关于这两个男人，圣诞老人蒂姆和圣诞老人尼克，如此相似，在伟大的事业中本应是盟友，却反而成了惨烈的圣诞老人内战中敌对派系的领导者。甚至成了死对头的故事。这是尼克在谈论蒂姆。
I won't say Tim's never helped another Santa, but typically when I look back now I can see where typically, wherever Tim's helped someone, it's always been to help Tim.
我不会说蒂姆从未帮助过其他圣诞老人，但通常当我回首往事时，我能看出，蒂姆帮助过的人，总是为了帮助蒂姆自己。
And here's Tim on Nick.
这是蒂姆谈论尼克。
You don't want to sit there. You hate to sit there and say someone is a liar. But on one hand, you've got to say, just show us the proof.
你不想坐在那里。你不愿意坐在那里说某人是骗子。但一方面，你必须说，只要给我们看证据。
Santa Tim and Santa Nick are at the center of a political schism that's overtaken their guild, the Amalgamated Order of Real Bearded Santas.
圣诞老人蒂姆和圣诞老人尼克正处于一场席卷他们公会的政治分裂的中心，那个公会叫“真实胡须圣诞老人联合会”。
It all began over a decade ago before Nick and Tim ever met, when a random event thrust a group of like-minded Santa's together.
这一切开始于十多年前，在尼克和蒂姆相识之前，当时一个偶然的事件让一群志同道合的圣诞老人聚在了一起。
Back in 1994, a German catalog assembled 10 professional Santas for a commercial shoot in Los Angeles. One Santa flipped through the catalog in his sleigh while the others bumped into each other in a gift delivery frenzy. Bob Kokol was one of those Santas.
1994年，一本德国目录为了在洛杉矶进行商业拍摄召集了10名职业圣诞老人。一位圣诞老人坐在他的雪橇里翻看目录，而其他人在礼物派送的狂热中互相碰撞。鲍勃·科科尔就是其中一位圣诞老人。
And we just had such a good time telling stories to each other during the breaks. One of the fellows, Tom Hartsfield, after it was all over he said, oh, we've got to get together after Christmas and have lunch together. And so we did. We met at the North Woods Inn there on the Santa Anna Freeway.
在休息时间，我们互相讲故事玩得非常开心。其中一位同伴汤姆·哈茨菲尔德在一切结束后说，噢，我们得在圣诞节后聚在一起吃个午饭。所以我们就做了。我们在圣安娜高速公路旁的North Woods Inn见了面。
That's the restaurant that's covered in snow? Fake snow.
那是那个被雪覆盖的餐厅吗？人造雪。
Yeah.
是的。
All these Santas had real beards, distinguishing them from the many synthetic or designer bearded Santas who often showed up at casting calls. A Santa named Tom Hartsfield jokingly proposed that they all form a club. He suggested the name, the Amalgamated Order of Real Bearded Santas, quickly known by its acronym, AORBS, and organized the luncheon. And the joke sort of took hold. The Santas met again the next year, and the next. And each time more Santas showed up.
所有这些圣诞老人都有真正的胡须，这使他们区别于许多经常在选角时出现的合成或人造胡须圣诞老人。一位叫汤姆·哈茨菲尔德的圣诞老人开玩笑地提议他们都成立一个俱乐部。他建议名字叫“真实胡须圣诞老人联合会”，很快以其缩写AORBS而闻名，并组织了那次午餐。那个笑话似乎成了真的。第二年，圣诞老人又见了面，接着是第三年。每次参加的圣诞老人越来越多。
And then this North Woods Inn just got too small. Sometimes we'd have 200 or 300 and they just couldn't fit all in. So then we had to go to someplace else. And then it was the Queen Mary and it just kept getting bigger and bigger and bigger. And then there had to be a president and a treasurer and a sergeant at arms and all these titles.
然后North Woods Inn就变得太小了。有时我们会有200或300人，他们根本装不下。所以我们不得不去别的地方。然后是玛丽皇后号，规模越来越大。然后必须要有主席、财务主管、警卫员和所有这些头衔。
By 2003, there were several hundred members. Until then, Tom Hartsfield had maintained all the administrative duties himself. Feeling overwhelmed, he was looking for help. One of the many people who joined the organization was Santa Tim Conaghan. This is the Santa Tim from the beginning of our story, the one who sang to me. Santa Tim was a well-known Santa in Southern California. He always had good gigs and under the name, the Kringle Group LLC, he ran various Santa related businesses. Including a referral service and mail order wardrobe catalog, offering boots, coats, buckles, and of course, beards made from yak fur, the preferred fake beard if you must wear fake. Which doesn't come cheap by the way.
到2003年，已经有几百名成员了。在那之前，汤姆·哈茨菲尔德一直独自承担所有的行政职责。感到不堪重负的他正在寻求帮助。加入该组织的许多人之一就是圣诞老人蒂姆·科纳汉。这就是故事开头提到的圣诞老人蒂姆，那个给我唱歌的人。圣诞老人蒂姆是南加州非常有名的圣诞老人。他总是能接到很好的活儿，并以Kringle Group LLC的名义经营各种圣诞相关业务。包括一个推荐服务和邮购服装目录，提供靴子、外套、带扣，当然还有牦牛毛胡须，如果你必须戴假胡须的话，这是首选的假胡须。顺便说一句，这可不便宜。
Santa Tim also had a school called the International University of Santa Claus, built around his own curriculum and textbook, Behind the Red Suit . All this meant that Santa Tim was an organizer, good on the computer with lists and events. Just what Tom thought this growing organization needed. So he asked Santa Tim to take over.
圣诞老人蒂姆还有一个叫“国际圣诞老人大学”的学校，建立在他自己的课程和教科书《红套装背后》的基础上。所有这一切意味着圣诞老人蒂姆是个组织者，擅长使用电脑制作列表和活动。这正是汤姆认为这个不断增长的组织所需要的。所以他请求圣诞老人蒂姆接管。
When Tom asked me to coordinate the group I started restructuring it to be a dues paying organization because we'd get $15 a year dues. Really, a small amount of money. But with that, we could have a website. A bigger website with more information. We could have newsletters and a chat group, or a web location where everybody could talk with each other. I put all of those things together. Again, I was traveling around doing my school, plus coordinating the association. At that time I thought it was kind of a neat thing because we were helping each other. My business was growing, the association was growing. The association actually went from about 200 on the meeting list to almost 1,300 on the meeting list. And while I was doing all that, like I said, the Santas were saying, well, when are we all going to get together?
当汤姆请求我协调该组织时，我开始对其进行重组，使其成为一个付费组织，因为我们当时要收每人每年15美元的会费。金额确实很少。但有了它，我们可以拥有一个网站。一个带有更多信息的大型网站。我们可以有通讯和聊天群，或者一个大家可以交流的网站位置。我把所有这些东西整合在一起。再说一次，我当时正四处奔波进行我的巡回教学，还要协调该协会。那时我觉得这真是一件很好的事情，因为我们在互相帮助。我的生意在增长，该协会也在增长。该协会的会议名单实际上从大约200人增加到近1,300人。而在我做这一切的同时，就像我说的，圣诞老人都在问，我们什么时候能聚在一起？
So I put together their first Santa convention.
所以我筹划了他们的第一次圣诞老人大会。
This is video from that convention, which was called Discover Santa 2006. And what we're hearing is the sound of over 300 real bearded Santa Clauses, their associated Mrs. Clauses, and a contingent of little people dressed as elves taking to the streets, a red and white procession across downtown Branson, Missouri at 7:00 AM on a Friday morning.
这是那次大会的录像，名为“发现圣诞老人2006”。我们听到的是超过300名真实胡须圣诞老人，他们的圣诞夫人，以及一队打扮成精灵的小人们走上街头，周五早上7点，在密苏里州布兰森市中心进行的一场红白相间的游行。
There were also advanced Santa panels on dealing with special needs children, and Santa Tim offered his Santa University lessons.
还有关于应对特殊需求儿童的高级圣诞老人小组讨论，圣诞老人蒂姆提供了他的圣诞老人大学课程。
Hello everyone, welcome back. I'm Santa Tim and we're going to move on to chapter two.
大家好，欢迎回来。我是圣诞老人蒂姆，我们将进入第二章。
These included the always popular Santa grooming practicum, covering beard, care and whitening. And simple do's and don'ts. Do smile, don't promise any specific toys. And of course--
其中包括广受欢迎的圣诞老人美容实践课，涵盖胡须护理和美白。以及简单的注意事项。多笑，不要承诺任何具体的玩具。当然——
Always remember the reindeer's names. I'm surprised that you have to ask that, but the thing is, guess what? We have Santas who forget the reindeer's names.
永远记住驯鹿的名字。我很惊讶你们竟然要问这个，但事实是，猜猜怎么着？我们有些圣诞老人会忘记驯鹿的名字。
Then there are those Santa nuances, Tim advises, that ought to be a matter of individual styling.
蒂姆建议，还有那些圣诞老人的细微差别，应该是个人的造型问题。
Ho, ho, ho's are important. Some people say you've got to do three in a row. I know some Santas that just do, ho, ho, how are you? In other words, they go right from a ho, ho into a sentence. Ho, ho, hello. Instead of doing all three. There's different ways of doing it. Come up with your own little signature. Have some fun with it.
“嚯、嚯、嚯”很重要。有些人说你必须连续做三个。我知道有些圣诞老人只是做，“嚯、嚯、你好吗？”换句话说，他们直接从“嚯、嚯”转到句子。嚯、嚯、你好。而不是全部做完。有不同的做法。想出你自己的标志性方式。享受其中吧。
Discover Santa was a success. It wasn't just the first national gathering of AORBS, it was an eye-opening experience for everyone. Being Santa Claus is a solitary job after all. As one Santa put it, "You can't just call a friend and go santaing together." But there they were, several hundred Santas, aglow with the promise of Santa fraternity. It was like their Woodstock and it raised the profile of the organization, generating all kinds of news coverage.
“发现圣诞老人”大会很成功。这不仅是AORBS的第一次全国集会，也是每个人大开眼界的经历。毕竟，当圣诞老人是一份孤独的工作。正如一位圣诞老人所说，“你不能随便叫个朋友一起去扮演圣诞老人。”但他们就在那里，几百名圣诞老人，沉浸在圣诞兄弟情谊的承诺中。就像是他们的伍德斯托克音乐节，提高了该组织的知名度，产生了各种新闻报道。
Tim turned AORBS into an official nonprofit. He assembled an interim board and drafted bylaws cribbed from the Kiwanis club. And meanwhile, all the media attention was attracting new members. One of whom was Nick Trolli, the other embattled Santa from the beginning of the story. He'd been quietly plying his trade as a part-time Santa, unaware of the organization run by Tim.
蒂姆把AORBS变成了一个正式的非营利组织。他组建了一个临时董事会，并从基瓦尼斯俱乐部借用了章程。与此同时，所有的媒体关注吸引了新成员。其中之一就是尼克·特罗利，故事开头提到的另一位陷入困境的圣诞老人。他一直在默默地从事兼职圣诞老人的工作，不知道蒂姆运营的这个组织。
I don't remember why but one day I just did a search of Santa on the Internet and I was like, well, wow. I think I might have been looking to replace a suit. But anyway, I did a search and I came up with Santa and then I found the Amalgamated Order of Real Bearded Santas. I said, well, gee, isn't that kind of cool?
我不记得为什么，但有一天我在互联网上搜索圣诞老人，我当时想，哇，太棒了。我想我可能是想换一身套装。但无论如何，我搜索了一下，找到了圣诞老人，然后发现了“真实胡须圣诞老人联合会”。我说，哇，这不是很酷吗？
Nick attended a meeting in New Jersey and immediately got involved. He joined the board and volunteered to help plan the next bigger Discover Santa convention. This was all in the Spring of 2007. No one knew it then, but that was the high water mark of the Amalgamated Order of Real Bearded Santas. Less than a year later, the organization would descend into chaos, then split in two.
尼克参加了在新泽西举行的一次会议，并立即参与其中。他加入了董事会，并自愿帮助筹划下一次规模更大的“发现圣诞老人”大会。这一切都发生在2007年春天。当时没人知道，那是“真实胡须圣诞老人联合会”的鼎盛时期。不到一年后，该组织将陷入混乱，然后一分为二。
The trouble began just a few months after Nick joined. When he started on the board, Nick clashed with Tim immediately. Nick accused Tim of using AORBS to profit his own Kringle Group businesses, and he started whispering to some of the other Santas about it.
麻烦在尼克加入后仅几个月就开始了。当他开始进入董事会时，尼克立即与蒂姆发生了冲突。尼克指责蒂姆利用AORBS来为他自己的Kringle Group业务谋利，并开始向其他一些圣诞老人低语。
Then that summer, it was learned that Santa Tim had signed a contract with a small film production company that hoped to make a movie about the Santa convention and Tim's Santa school. Tim signed contracts on behalf of his school and AORBS. Both were paid $1,500 up front, with more coming if the movie ever got made. It wasn't a lot of money, but it was enough to be considered a scandal. .
然后那年夏天，人们得知圣诞老人蒂姆与一家小型电影制作公司签署了一份合同，该公司希望能拍摄一部关于圣诞老人大会和蒂姆圣诞老人学校的电影。蒂姆代表他的学校和AORBS签署了合同。两者都预付了1,500美元，如果电影真的拍成了，还会有更多报酬。这笔钱虽然不多，但足以被视为丑闻。
The dispute hit the board and eventually, Santa Tim resigned. In the fall out, several more board members resigned in solidarity. Which meant that by order of succession, Santa Nick who had just joined that year, wound up president of AORBS.
争议冲击了董事会，最终，圣诞老人蒂姆辞职了。在后果中，几名董事会成员为了声援他也辞职了。这意味着根据继任顺序，当年才加入的圣诞老人尼克，成了AORBS的主席。
Next thing I know, all of a sudden, Tim starts attacking me every which way I turned. And not just Tim, but his cronies like this nut case, Rick Erwin. He called me brain damaged. He accused me of stealing. And he got these people all riled up and he's got the California Santas all riled up.
接下来的事我不知道，突然间，蒂姆开始从各个方向攻击我。不仅是蒂姆，还有像里奇·欧文这种疯子这样的走狗。他称我脑损伤。他指责我偷窃。他把这些人煽动起来，并把加利福尼亚的圣诞老人们都煽动起来了。
The reason the California Santas were all riled up is that they believe Santa Nick had essentially staged a coup, beginning with his whisper campaign against Tim. To them, this was a power grab plain and simple. And to make matters worse, Santa Nick started doing some things that seemed very suspicious. He dropped the word "interim" from his title. He reincorporated the entire organization in another state. He never accounted for the treasury. And he installed another relatively new Santa, Jeff Germann, as his vice president. Which gave Jeff control over the Santa's online forum, Elf Net. Which is where dissident Santas were airing their grievances.
加利福尼亚圣诞老人被煽动起来的原因是他们认为圣诞老人尼克本质上策划了一场政变，从他针对蒂姆的低语运动开始。对他们来说，这简直就是一场权力争夺。更糟糕的是，圣诞老人尼克开始做一些看起来非常可疑的事情。他从自己的头衔中删除了“临时”一词。他在另一个州重新注册了整个组织。他从未说明过资金状况。而且他任命了另一位相对较新的圣诞老人杰夫·格曼为副主席。这使得杰夫控制了圣诞老人的在线论坛“精灵网”。而那里正是持不同政见的圣诞老人发泄怨气的地方。
Rick Erwin was one of those dissident Santas and he says things changed when Santa Jeff took over Elf Net.
里奇·欧文就是其中一位持不同政见的圣诞老人，他说当圣诞老人杰夫接管“精灵网”时，情况发生了变化。
That's when the bannings began. Once the chat function had moved to his server, he controlled the chat from that moment on. And any postings that were antithetical to Nick Trolli or Jeff Germann were deleted within hours. It was like Orwell's 1984 . The ministry of truth moved in and unwrote everything in the history books.
那就是封禁开始的时候。一旦聊天功能转移到他的服务器上，从那一刻起他就控制了聊天。任何反对尼克·特罗利或杰夫·格曼的帖子都会在几小时内被删除。就像奥威尔的《1984》一样。真理部搬了进来，改写了历史书里的一切。
From Nick and Jeff's perspective, they were the ones facing a coordinated assault coming from Tim's cabal of rabid supporters. Jeff Germann says they had to defend themselves against nonstop rumors and innuendo. And pretty soon, this meant going head to head against the guy who came up with the idea for the organization in the first place, the guy who named it the Amalgamated Order of Real Bearded Santas, Santa Tom Hartsfield.
从尼克和杰夫的角度来看，他们才是面临来自蒂姆狂热支持者团伙协调攻击的人。杰夫·格曼说他们必须为抵御不断的谣言和影射而自卫。很快，这意味着要与最初提出该组织构思的那个人，也就是为它命名为“真实胡须圣诞老人联合会”的人，汤姆·哈茨菲尔德正面交锋。
Well, Tom decided to start posting on the message board publicly undermining stuff we were working on and causing dissension in the group. And so, since I was in charge of the message board, the first thing I did when he published this was I deleted the thread that he started, and then I removed his access from the message board. And let him know that this would be taken up with the board next time we meet to see about whether you get your access back or not.
嗯，汤姆决定开始在留言板上公开破坏我们正在做的事情，并引起群体内的分裂。所以，由于我负责留言板，当他发布这个时，我做的第一件事就是删除了他发起的帖子，然后我取消了他对留言板的访问权限。并让他知道，这件事会在我们下次开会时由董事会讨论，看看他能否恢复访问权限。
Well, he didn't like that. That's what made him mad about quitting. Because I had the temerity to rebuke him and discipline him on our message board.
好吧，他不喜欢那样。那就是让他对退出感到愤怒的原因。因为我有胆量在我们的留言板上训斥和管教他。
Now, rebuke is not a word you hear in conversation that often, and Jeff used it three times. All that rebuking reminds you that although Santas are self described jolly gentleman, they also divide the world into naughty and nice.
训斥这个词在谈话中不常听到，杰夫用了三次。所有的训斥提醒你，虽然圣诞老人是自称快乐的绅士，但他们也把世界分为“顽皮”和“友善”。
By the fall of 2007, lots of santas were being labeled naughty, and a vicious cycle developed. The more Santas who criticized Nick and Jeff, the more Santas got banished. Which led to more criticism, which prompted more banishment. A siege mentality set in. Eventually, the deposed Santas started their own forums, Santa Talk, which they called a refugee camp from AORBS.
到2007年秋天，许多圣诞老人被贴上了“顽皮”的标签，陷入了一个恶性循环。批评尼克和杰夫的圣诞老人越多，被封禁的圣诞老人就越多。这导致了更多的批评，从而导致更多的封禁。一种围城心态形成了。最终，被废黜的圣诞老人开始建立他们自己的论坛，“圣诞老人谈话”，他们称之为AORBS的难民营。
Now each faction had its own mouthpiece, further fanning the flames. Each side accused the other of betraying the spirit of Santa Claus, of using the beard to line their own red velvet pockets.
现在每个派系都有了自己的喉舌，进一步煽风点火。每一方都指责对方背叛了圣诞老人的精神，利用胡须来填充自己的红天鹅绒口袋。
The conflict came to a head in January 2008, at a big AORBS meeting at Knott's Berry Farm in Beuna Park, California. This was the first time member Santas were meeting with the new board and many were looking for answers. One of those was Santa Rick, the dissident Santa you just heard comparing the situation to Orwell. At the time, he was still lodge director for the Inland Empire AORBS chapter and he planned to record the board meet and greet on video.
冲突在2008年1月达到顶峰，当时在加利福尼亚州布埃纳公园的诺特浆果农场举行了一次盛大的AORBS会议。这是成员圣诞老人第一次与新董事会会面，许多人都在寻找答案。其中之一是圣诞老人里奇，刚才听到将这种情况与奥威尔相比较的持不同政见圣诞老人。当时，他仍然是内陆帝国AORBS分会的旅店主管，他计划在视频中记录这次董事会见面会。
I showed up at the hotel and I walked up, there was a Santa standing near the desk talking to a couple of kids and their mom. And so I walked up to the desk. I was going to ask where the meeting was and when he saw me, the Santa saw he, turned to me and said, hi, can I help you? And I said, where's the Santa meeting? And he kind of pointed up the stairs off the lobby and he said, why? And I said, I'm here for the meeting. Thanks. And I turned around and started up the stairs. And he said, where you going with that camera? And at that point I realized, he was either Nick Trolli or Jeff Germann. I'd never met either man personally, but I knew them online.
我出现在酒店，走到前台，有一个圣诞老人站在柜台附近和几个孩子以及他们的妈妈说话。所以我走到前台。我打算问会议在哪里举行，当他看到我时，那个圣诞老人转向我说，嗨，我能帮你吗？我说，圣诞老人会议在哪里？他指着大堂外的楼梯说，为什么？我说，我是来参加会议的。谢谢。我转身开始上楼梯。他说，你带着摄像机要去哪儿？在那一点上我意识到，他要么是尼克·特罗利，要么是杰夫·格曼。我从未亲自见过这两个人，但我从网上认识他们。
And at that point I knew he was one or the other. So I reached down and turned on my video camera and started recording.
在那一点上我知道他是其中之一。所以我伸手打开了我的摄像机并开始录像。
You're not filming anything, Rick.
你没在拍任何东西，里奇。
Oh yes, I am.
哦，是的，我在拍。
No you're not, Rick.
不，你没有，里奇。
I'm sorry to tell you, but this an open meeting, sir. I take it you're Jeff.
很抱歉告诉你，但这是个公开会议，先生。我想你是杰夫吧。
No, I'm Nick. I'd like to speak with you.
不，我是尼克。我想和你谈谈。
What's your name?
你叫什么名字？
I'm Nick.
我是尼克。
Nick. Oh, you're Nick Trolli. Nice to meet you, Nick. Finally, meet you after all this time.
尼克。噢，你是尼克·特罗利。很高兴见到你，尼克。终于，在这段时间之后见到你了。
And by that time we were at the top of the stairs and headed down the hallway. And he was met by his other board members, three other. There were five Santas in the hallway. Myself and four AORBS board members. Nick Trolli and Jeff Germann stopped me. Jeff Germann actually got in front of me and stopped me in the hallway.
那时我们已经到了楼梯顶端，沿着走廊走。他遇到了他的其他三名董事会成员。走廊里有五名圣诞老人。我和四名AORBS董事会成员。尼克·特罗利和杰夫·格曼拦住了我。杰夫·格曼实际上走到了我前面，在走廊里拦住了我。
Mr. Erwin here thinks he's going to film.
欧文先生认为他要拍电影。
No, you're not.
不，你不能。
I got news for you, Mr. Erwin's already videotaping.
我得告诉你个消息，欧文先生已经在录像了。
This is for the membership.
这是给成员看的。
That's fine.
那很好。
I represent officially two of the four chapters in Southern California.
我正式代表南加州的四个分会中的两个。
That's fine.
那很好。
And this is an open meeting for the membership. And I've been specifically--
这是一个对成员开放的会议。我被明确地——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（干扰声音）
Listen, I'm videotaping this meeting.
听着，我正在录制这个会议。
No you're not.
不，你不能。
I'm already videotaping this confrontation.
我已经在这个对抗中录像了。
At this point on the tape, Santa Rick's camera is on, but dangling in his hand. So all you can see is a jerky dash for the conference room until he is stopped by that group of Santas. We get a waist level view of the large torsos gathering around Rick. Legs and round bellies, and at least one knotted wooden cane. Another pair of legs wanders into the frame wearing knee breeches, red and white striped socks, and buckled shoes. The argument continues.
在录像的这一点上，圣诞老人里奇的摄像机开着，但悬在他手中。所以你只能看到一个急躁的冲向会议室的镜头，直到他被那群圣诞老人拦住。我们看到了大型躯干聚集在里奇周围的腰部水平视角。腿和圆肚子，以及至少一根打结的木手杖。另一双腿走进了画面，穿着及膝马裤、红白条纹袜子和带扣的鞋子。争论继续。
The whole thing lasted about 30 seconds and I said, listen, I'm not going to argue with you about this. And I turned to go on into the meeting. And as I went past Jeff German, he raised his arm and shoved me into the wall with all of my camera equipment, my tripod over my shoulder, I was carrying my camera. And he bounced me off of the hallway wall. The shove felt round the world. And at that instant, you can hear me, say, don't touch me again.
整个过程持续了大约30秒，我说，听着，我不打算和你争论这件事。我转身向会议室走去。当我走过杰夫·格曼时，他抬起手臂把我撞到了墙上，我带着所有的摄像器材，肩膀上背着三脚架，我带着摄像机。他把我从走廊墙上弹开了。那一下推搡震惊了全世界。在那一刻，你可以听到我说，别再碰我。
You know what, don't touch me again.
你知道吗，别再碰我。
Yeah, he says I attacked him. He says that I beat him up at Nick's behest.
是的，他说我攻击了他。他说我在尼克的指使下殴打了他。
This is Jeff Germann, Nick's vice president, who disputes the entire story.
这是杰夫·格曼，尼克的副主席，他反驳了整个故事。
He said that I elbowed him. He says I laid hands on him. He says I punched him, which is obvious because when it was done he was on the floor with a broken nose and a broken leg. Just kidding. All that really happened is he pushed past me. And that's all that happened.
他说我用肘部顶他。他说我对他动了手。他说我打了他的拳头，这很明显，因为当结束后他倒在地上，鼻子断了，腿也断了。开个玩笑。发生的一切就是他从我身边挤了过去。这就是发生的一切。
Are you tall?
你很高吗？
I'm 6'4''.
我6英尺4英寸。
OK. So you are a big Santa?
好的。所以你是个大块头圣诞老人？
Yeah, I'm just as big as Christmas.
是的，我和圣诞节一样大。
It's impossible to tell exactly what happened from the tape because of the waist level vantage point. Although each side says it proves their point. Some kind of physical contact occurred. That much can be said from the way the camera shakes a little. But more importantly, Rick gets free and marches into the meeting.
从录像中无法确切说出发生了什么，因为视线是在腰部。尽管双方都说这证明了他们的观点。发生了一些身体接触。从摄像机的震动方式来看，至少可以肯定这一点。但更重要的是，里奇挣脱出来，大步走进会议室。
Excuse me.
打扰一下。
Hey Rick.
嘿，里奇。
But one Santa knocked me into the wall, the big guy.
但有一个圣诞老人把我撞到了墙上，那个大块头。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I've already been physically assaulted, but I'm not going to stop taping.
是的。我已经受到人身攻击了，但我不会停止录像。
On the tape, the Santa Rick sets up in the corner. You can see that the meeting hasn't started and the Santa's are milling around chatting. Then Santa Nick storms in and makes the following demand.
在录像中，圣诞老人里奇设置在角落。你可以看到会议还没开始，圣诞老人们正在走动聊天。然后圣诞老人尼克冲进来，提出了以下要求。
I'm asking you one more time, please take the down camera and leave.
我再问你一次，请把摄像机放下并离开。
On what authority?
凭什么授权？
On the authority AORBS rent this room.
凭AORBS租下这个房间的授权。
I'm sorry, you're going to have to quote the bylaws and you're going to have to ask all of the members to leave. I'm here representing two of the four Southern California chapters.
对不起，你得引用章程，你得请求所有成员离开。我在这里代表南加州四个分会中的两个。
Rick, I represent 877 members of AORBS.
里奇，我代表AORBS的877名成员。
That's under question quite frankly, but I officially represent--
坦率地说，这一点有疑问，但我正式代表——
I'm ordering you to leave our premises.
我命令你离开我们的场地。
I refuse to leave voluntarily.
我拒绝自愿离开。
Security, escort him out please.
保安，请把他赶出去。
You don't have the right to pull him.
你没有权利拉他。
Excuse me, this man is enforcing rules that do not exist.
打扰一下，这个人正在执行不存在的规则。
The hotel security guard takes just a few steps before he realizes he's in over his head. It's likely his training did not prepare him to walk into a room full of angry Santa Clauses. For starters, they all look the same. It's hard to tell who's on whose side. He pauses, looks at all the big men with beards looking back at him, turns around, and goes for backup.
酒店保安只走了几步就意识到他自己应付不来。他的训练很可能没有让他准备好走进一个满是愤怒的圣诞老人的房间。首先，他们看起来都一样。很难分清谁是哪一边的。他停顿了一下，看着所有回望他的留着胡子的大块头，转身，去找援军。
In the stunned silence that follows, you can see a few arched white eyebrows around the room.
在随后的震惊寂静中，你可以看到房间周围有几对拱起的白眉毛。
This tyranny must end, guys. This tyranny must end.
这种暴政必须结束，伙计们。这种暴政必须结束。
Jeff, I [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
杰夫，我……
You're Santa for God's sake.
看在上帝的份上，你是圣诞老人。
This isn't the Night of the Long Knives, guys.
这不是“长刀之夜”，伙计们。
If you didn't quite catch it, Rick says, this isn't the Night of Long Knives. For those not up to speed on your Third Reich history, that's the day in 1934 when Adolf Hitler consolidated his control over the Nazi party by killing or jailing all of his enemies.
如果你没完全听懂，里奇说，这不是长刀之夜。对于那些对第三帝国历史不了解的人来说，那是1934年阿道夫·希特勒通过杀害或监禁所有敌人来巩固对纳粹党控制的那一天。
Eventually, the Knott's Berry Farm hotel security chief shows up with two other guys and approaches Rick.
最终，诺特浆果农场酒店的保安主管带着另外两个人出现，并接近里奇。
I'm a supervisor of the hotel. These folks are asking you to leave. Gentleman back there is the one who booked the event. He doesn't want you here, so you need to leave.
我是酒店的主管。这些人请你离开。后面那位绅士是预订活动的人。他不想让你待在这儿，所以你需要离开。
I mean I got three rules that I live life by. I won't be lied to or about, I won't be stolen from, and I will not be laid hands upon. And in my opinion, these guys violated all three of my core codes. And we went to war.
我是说我有三条我生活的原则。我不会被欺骗，我不会被偷窃，我也绝不会被动手动脚。在我看来，这些人违反了我所有三条核心准则。我们开战了。
The war was hard fought. Rick posted his video of the kerfuffle online sparking outrage.
战争打得很艰难。里奇把他的冲突录像发布到网上，引发了愤怒。
Some Santas renounced their membership in protest. The rhetoric escalated, especially on the Santa forums, where Rick and others accused Nick of embezzlement. And Nick accused the breakaway Santa's of sabotaging the Discover Santa 2008 convention, calling them economic terrorists. And declaring that AORBS blood is on their hands. Lawsuits were threatened back and forth on a regular basis. And Nick told various Santas he was going to lodge complaints against them with the FBI.
一些圣诞老人为了抗议退出了成员资格。言辞升级，特别是在圣诞老人论坛上，里奇和其他人指责尼克挪用公款。而尼克指责分裂出的圣诞老人破坏了“发现圣诞老人2008”大会，称他们是经济恐怖分子。并声称AORBS的鲜血在他们手上。诉讼威胁经常在双方之间发生。尼克告诉不同的圣诞老人，他要向FBI投诉他们。
At a certain point, lines were crossed that no Santa would have thought possible. A website appeared called Santa Check, which purports to be an independent watchdog group for parents, but appears to actually be a sub rosa propaganda campaign targeting Nick's enemies.
在某个时候，越过了没有任何圣诞老人会认为可能的底线。出现了一个叫“圣诞老人检查”的网站，它声称是一个给父母的独立监督组织，但实际上似乎是一个针对尼克敌人的秘密宣传活动。
One entry posted a still from a video of Santa Rick's birthday party. The relatively harmless video shows Santa Rick being entertained by a belly dancer and features Rick's unfortunate title, "How Santa Got his Yuletide Log Back." At the top of the web page is Santa Check's tagline, "is your child safe on this lap?" This unfair insinuation is the lowest of blows, the equivalent among Santas of the nuclear option.
其中一个条目发布了一张圣诞老人里奇生日派对视频的剧照。那个相对无害的视频显示圣诞老人里奇被肚皮舞者招待，并以里奇不幸的标题为特色，“圣诞老人是如何找回他的圣诞木头的”。网页的顶部是“圣诞老人检查”的口号，“你的孩子在这条腿上安全吗？”这种不公平的暗示是最低级的打击，在圣诞老人之间等同于核选择。
The hardest thing to understand about this story is how it got to this point. The allegations and counter-allegations are so outlandish, that when I first started looking into all this it wasn't just difficult to figure out which side was right, I had a hard time understanding what actually happened.
关于这个故事最难理解的是它是如何走到这一步的。指控和反指控如此离谱，以至于当我第一次开始调查这一切时，不仅很难弄清楚哪一方是正确的，我还很难理解实际上发生了什么。
I spent weeks talking to Santas and reading their discussion boards trying to sort it out. It wasn't easy. When I talked to the Santas, it was like the Israeli Palestinian conflict. Each side had its own distinct narrative about the history of the war, and the two narratives did not overlap. In the end, here's what I think probably happened.
我花了几周时间与圣诞老人谈话，阅读他们的讨论板，试图弄清真相。这并不容易。当我与圣诞老人谈话时，感觉就像巴以冲突。每一方都有自己独特的关于战争历史的叙述，而这两个叙述没有重叠。最后，我想这就是可能发生的事情。
Santa Tim's businesses had profited a little from AORBS, sure. But then Santa Nick came in and he was drunk with power. Then the other side overreacted, Nick quickly turned into a Santa Stalin, and the whole thing just evolved from there. It was the same dynamic that starts real wars. The further people get drawn into a fight, the harder it is to back down. The fact that this could happen to a group of Santas just proves it could happen to anybody.
圣诞老人蒂姆的业务确实从AORBS获利了一点，当然。但随后圣诞老人尼克进来了，他被权力冲昏了头脑。然后另一方反应过度，尼克很快变成了一个“圣诞老人斯大林”，整个事情就是从那里发展起来的。这是启动真正战争的相同动力。人们越深陷于战斗中，就越难退缩。这种情况能发生在一群圣诞老人身上，正好证明了它能发生在任何人身上。
By last summer, AORBS membership plummeted as several local Santa leaders filed articles of separation from AORBS, citing Nick and Jeff's persecutory atmosphere and the un-Santa-like dialogue.
到去年夏天，AORBS的成员急剧下降，因为几个地方圣诞老人领袖提交了脱离AORBS的章程，引用了尼克和杰夫的迫害气氛以及非圣诞老人的对话。
One Santa issued a statement calling for a Santa Claus congress in the spirit of the American Revolution. Around the country, regional groups sprang up in the vacuum. Nick and Jeff were despots in a shrinking kingdom.
一位圣诞老人发表声明，呼吁以美国革命的精神召开圣诞老人大会。在全国范围内，区域性团体在真空里涌现。尼克和杰夫成了不断缩小的王国里的暴君。
Soon they were the only active board members left, and the remaining members were still waiting for elections. When they eventually did hold elections, their war what the United Nations might call irregularities. Nick and Jeff formed a nominating committee, but required their own approval over the committee's selections. This is Santa Tom Irving, a board member at the time.
很快，他们成了仅存的活跃董事会成员，剩余成员仍在等待选举。当他们最终确实举行选举时，他们的战争被联合国称为违规。尼克和杰夫组建了一个提名委员会，但要求委员会的选择必须经过他们自己的批准。这是圣诞老人汤姆·欧文，当时的董事会成员。
They were looking for reasons to disqualify anybody who was nominated. There were several people nominated for president. And everyone was disqualified. Nick was the only name on the ballot. They found reasons to disqualify everybody who was up for first vice president. Only Jeff Germann was on the ballot. You know, what it reminded me of is, what was it, Robert Mugabe? Held the election in South Africa someplace and he was the only one on the ballot.
他们寻找理由取消任何被提名人的资格。有几个人被提名为主席。每个人都被取消了资格。尼克是选票上唯一的候选人。他们找理由取消了每一位竞争第一副主席的人的资格。只有杰夫·格曼在选票上。你知道，这让我想起了什么？是罗伯特·穆加贝吗？在南非某地举行选举，他是选票上唯一的候选人。
To Santa Tim and his followers, AORBS no longer exists. What is called AORBS is an impostor, sidelined and irrelevant. To Nick and Jeff, AORBS is still the home of the world's A-list Santas as they like to say. And they insist they will have their day in court.
对圣诞老人蒂姆和他的追随者来说，AORBS已不复存在。所谓的AORBS是一个冒名顶替者，被边缘化且无关紧要。对尼克和杰夫来说，AORBS仍然是他们所说的世界顶级圣诞老人的家园。他们坚持说他们会到法庭上一见分晓。
Recently however, the war slowed down a bit. Mostly by virtue of seasonal logistics. All the Santas have been busy in their chairs twinkling their eyes at children and doing what Santas are supposed to do. And they don't have as much time for mischief. Which is how it should be. It was during the offseason that Santas were free to endlessly argue with each other. That's when they lost sight of the larger picture. It takes a neutral Santa, some one like Tom Irving to see that.
不过最近，战争稍微放缓了一些。主要是由于季节性的后勤问题。所有的圣诞老人都忙于坐在椅子上向孩子们闪烁眼睛，做圣诞老人应该做的事。他们没有太多时间搞恶作剧。这正是它应有的样子。正是在休赛期，圣诞老人有空无休止地争吵。那时他们失去了大局观。需要一个中立的圣诞老人，像汤姆·欧文那样的人才能看到这一点。
I look at it as a real lesson in what happens when you let your own ego get in the way of things. You know, I've never been a person with a real strong ego. You've got to have a bit of that to be Santa Claus. You've got to have that kind of a personality where you're willing to step out into the world in front of people. It's like being an actor in a lot of ways. If you allow the ego to drive you, then you're doing it for the wrong reason. And that's what happened with these guys. I really believe that.
我把它看作是一个真正的教训，关于当你让自己的自负挡住事情的路时会发生什么。你知道，我从来不是一个自负心很强的人。当圣诞老人你必须有那么一点自负。你必须拥有那种愿意在人们面前走入世界的人格。在很多方面就像做一个演员。如果你允许自负驱动你，那你就是为了错误的原因在做它。而这就是发生在这些人身上的事情。我真的这么认为。
Back when I first met Santa Tim at his workshop, we talked about the origins of Santa Claus. What people often don't realize is that Santa Claus was always a more complicated character than today's rosy-cheeked do-gooder. The original tradition of Saint Nicholas included a diabolical counterpart, the guy you met if you were naughty. This character goes by a lot of different names: Krampus, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], Belsnickel. And he's also in red, but with horns, a tail, and a pitch fork. Sound familiar? Santa's flip side is the devil. And it's not a coincidence that the devil is sometimes called Old Nick.
回想我第一次在工作室见到圣诞老人蒂姆时，我们谈到了圣诞老人的起源。人们通常没有意识到的是，圣诞老人一直是一个比当今红润脸蛋、行善者更复杂的人物。圣尼古拉斯的原始传统包括一个邪恶的对立面，如果你顽皮，你就会遇到那个人。这个角色有许多不同的名字：坎普斯、贝尔尼克尔。他也穿着红色，但长着角、尾巴和干草叉。听起来熟悉吗？圣诞老人的另一面是魔鬼。而且魔鬼有时被称为“老尼克”并非巧合。
The man in the red suit has always represented both sides of the coin, naughty and nice. This is what we're supposed to be reminded of during the darkest days of each year. We make mistakes and we sometimes do the wrong things, and so does Santa. And so maybe the story of AORBS is a Christmas parable after all.
那个穿红衣服的男人一直代表着硬币的两面，顽皮和友善。这就是我们每年在一年中最黑暗的日子里应该被提醒的。我们犯错误，有时做错事，圣诞老人也一样。所以也许AORBS的故事确实是一个圣诞寓言。
Josh Bearman in Los Angeles. In the two years since we first aired that story, AORBS has ceased to exist the way it was, a centralized group of Santas. The organization is still around, but 20 splinter groups have risen up. The largest of those is FORBS, the Fraternal Order of Real Bearded Santas, which is where Santa Tim Conaghan ended up.
洛杉矶的乔什·比尔曼。在那个故事首次播出以来的两年里，AORBS以原来的那种方式不复存在了，即一个集中的圣诞老人组织。该组织仍然存在，但已经出现了20个分裂团体。其中最大的是FORBS，“真实胡须圣诞老人兄弟会”，这就是圣诞老人蒂姆·科纳汉最终去的地方。
[MUSIC- "GET BEHIND ME SANTA" BY SUFJAN STEVENS]
（音乐 - 苏菲扬·斯蒂文斯的“跟随我圣诞老人”）
"Act four, Job Security."
“第四幕，工作保障。”
Back in a part of the mall that shoppers never go is an area that feels a lot like the backstage of a theater. The walls are made of plywood. You wind around these hallways that are two stories high with doors that lead into the backs of the stores. Turn a corner and you arrive at the security office. There's a snug little room here with 43 TV screens, one for each of the cameras in the hallways and the parking lots, the roof and the loading dock. The room is dark. Beverly Robertson watches the cameras and she likes it dark. She tells me and my co-producer Wendy Dorr, that two or three times a day, her job includes helping people find their parked cars in the vast lots that surround the mall.
回到商场里一个购物者从不去的地方，是一个感觉很像剧院后台的区域。墙壁是胶合板做的。你穿过这些两层楼高的走廊，门通向商店的后方。转过一个弯，你到达了保安办公室。这是一个舒适的小房间，有43个电视屏幕，每个屏幕对应走廊、停车场、屋顶和装卸货码头的摄像头。房间很暗。贝弗利·罗伯逊看着摄像头，她喜欢暗的地方。她告诉我和我的联合制片人温迪·多尔，她每天有两三次工作包括帮助人们在商场周围巨大的停车场里找到停放的车。
Usually though when they come to me, my car has been stolen. It's not where I parked it. But usually, they have just forgot where they've parked.
不过通常当他们来找我时，他们会说车被偷了。它不在我停车的地方。但通常，他们只是忘了把车停哪儿了。
About once a week, somebody who can't find their car actually accuses security of getting into the car and moving it to a different lot.
大约每周一次，有人找不到车，实际上会指责保安进入他们的车并把它移到了另一个停车场。
We do have a lot of that, well, you've just moved my car. I mean, like we have nothing better to do than go out and move your car. It's like we have everybody's sets of keys in our office. Oh, well, this one's parked here. Let's go move it for them. No, we don't do that.
我们确实遇到很多这种情况，好吧，你们肯定挪动了我的车。我是说，我们除了出去挪动你的车外没事可做了吗？好像我们的办公室里有每个人的钥匙链。噢，好吧，这辆停在这儿。我们去帮他们挪一下吧。不，我们不做那种事。
I go and wander around the mall with Beverly's boss, the head of security, Doug [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and one of the officers, Gary. Doug tells me about all the cases they get where a husband gets separated from his wife in the mall and then comes to security for help finding her.
我和贝弗利的老板，安保主管道格以及其中一名安保人员加里在商场里逛。道格告诉我所有他们处理的案例，丈夫在商场里和妻子走散了，然后来找安保寻求帮助找到她。
That's when the descriptions don't match anything they say. They don't know what their wives look like. They don't know what kind of hair they've got, haircut. You can say, is it down to their shoulders or is it up? What color is it? How tall is she? And don't ask them what they've got on.
那时，他们的描述与他们所说的任何东西都不符。他们不知道他们的妻子长什么样。他们不知道她们有什么样的头发，发型。你可以问，是到肩膀长还是短？什么颜色？她多高？而且别问她们穿什么。
They could just say, she's wearing a blue coat.
他们可能只是说，她穿着蓝色的外套。
And then they'll be wrong. They'll be wrong about that.
然后他们就会错了。他们在这点上会出错。
While Doug and Gary and I were talking, Wendy hung back in the security office with Beverly. They were watching us on the various TV monitors. Though, I didn't know that at the time.
当道格、加里和我交谈时，温迪在安保办公室里和贝弗利呆着。她们通过各种电视监视器看着我们。虽然当时我不知道。
For about 45 minutes we've been tracking them on the lower level, and it was surprisingly easy.
在大约45分钟的时间里，我们一直在下层跟踪他们，而且非常容易。
I see my boss, my lieutenant, and Ira. And they're pointing in-- they're coming up the south end escalator. You can see the top of their heads. I mean you could zoom in.
我看到了我的老板、中尉还有艾拉。他们正指着——他们正沿着南端的自动扶梯上来。你可以看到他们头顶。我是说你可以放大。
Let's just say you zoomed in till you could literally see the freckles on top of your boss's head.
咱们说你放大到你能字面上看到你老板头上的雀斑。
Yes, I mean you can if you want to. But it's just being funny.
是的，我是说如果你想的话可以。但这只是好玩。
Beverly's been working at the mall for 11 years. And for the last five years she's been here in dispatch, sitting at a desk, a foot away from the 43 little TV screens. She can tilt the cameras up and down, or turn them left and right. Or zoom in using her keyboard and joystick.
贝弗利已经在商场工作了11年。在过去的五年里，她一直在这里调度，坐在办公桌旁，离43个小电视屏幕只有一英尺。她可以上下倾斜摄像头，或左右转动。或者使用键盘和操纵杆进行放大。
She's looking for kids who stray away from their parents, or play on the escalators, for groups of rowdy teens, for people who've fallen down. For anything on the floor that someone could trip over, for anything out of the ordinary. Or anything that could lead to a lawsuit.
她寻找离开父母的孩子，或在自动扶梯上玩耍的孩子，寻找吵闹的青少年群体，寻找跌倒的人。寻找地上任何可能导致绊倒的东西，寻找任何不寻常的事情。或者任何可能导致诉讼的事情。
Most the time it's fun. You see stuff that you really sometimes don't want to see.
大多数时候很有趣。你看到了你有时真的不想看到的东西。
Like what do you mean?
你是说像什么？
We watched this guy one day, we had a kiosk that was upstairs, and this guy was standing there. The whole time that he was standing there he was picking his nose and wiping his boogers on the counter. And we were sitting back here laughing so hard that we couldn't stand it. But after the guy left and everything, we called the guy at the kiosk and told him, you need to get some sanitizer and kind of sanitize that desk. And he's like, why? And I said, well, he just wiped boogers all over your tables. This guy got really disgusted and threw up and it was just funny. But you do see some of the funniest stuff.
有一天我们看着这家伙，我们楼上有一个亭位，这个家伙站在那里。在他站着的整个时间里，他都在挖鼻孔，并把鼻屎擦在柜台上。我们坐在后面笑得停不下来。但在那个家伙离开后，我们给亭位的人打了电话，告诉他，你需要买点消毒液，把那个桌子消消毒。他说，为什么？我说，好吧，他刚刚把鼻屎擦在你所有的桌子上了。这个家伙感到非常恶心，吐了，这很有趣。但你确实会看到一些最有趣的事情。
She told me that when she gets home from work, she has to let her eyes rest for a few hours. So she can't watch much TV. Beverly works 10 hour shifts, 5 days a week, from 7:00 AM to 5:00. And when she's working, she doesn't like to take a break.
她告诉我，当她下班回家时，她必须让眼睛休息几个小时。所以她看不了多少电视。贝弗利每周工作5天，每天10小时，从早上7点到下午5点。当她在工作时，她不喜欢休息。
Is it hard to not shop?
不购物难吗？
No, I hate to shop. I'm not a big shopper at all. I've never been. I don't like shops. It's not very hard for me at all. Not hard at all.
不，我讨厌购物。我一点也不喜欢购物。我从来不喜欢。我不喜欢商店。对我来说一点也不难。一点也不难。
Are you getting your kids presents and stuff this Christmas?
你这个圣诞节给孩子们买礼物之类的吗？
Yes, but not here. I usually get mine like at Walmart, or Kmart, stores like that. There are a few stores in here that I would go to, but there's a lot of high end stores that-- I work all the time, so I don't have any clothes anymore because I never go anywhere. I'm always at work and at home with my kids. I don't buy clothes and shoes and stuff. I have uniforms and that's it. The best part of my day is going home and getting into a pair of blue jeans and a t-shirt. I mean that's just the best part of the day because you get out of the uniform.
是的，但不是在这里。我通常像在沃尔玛或凯马特之类的商店买我的。这里有几家店我会去，但这里有很多高端商店……我一直工作，所以我没有衣服穿了，因为我从不去任何地方。我总是在工作，在家里陪孩子。我不买衣服和鞋子之类的东西。我有制服，就是这样。我一天中最美好的时光是回家换上一条牛仔裤和一件T恤。我是说那是一天中最美好的时光，因为你脱掉了制服。
Beverly likes it when it's busy, when the phone's ringing with people who need her help. The toughest part of the job seems to be fighting off boredom.
贝弗利喜欢忙碌的时候，当电话响着需要她帮助的人的时候。工作中看来最难的部分是抵御无聊。
We used to have a spider that would get on our cameras on the outside. It would get on the lens and you could zoom until you went straight through it. You zoomed out so much that it just goes right through it. I mean you can't see the spider anymore, but you know it's there.
我们以前在室外的摄像头上有一只蜘蛛。它会爬到镜头上，你可以放大直到你直接穿过它。你缩小到无法再看到蜘蛛，但你知道它在那里。
We do all kinds of things in here when we get bored.
我们无聊的时候在这里做各种事情。
Beverly's leaving early today. She lives in Spring Hill, which is about 20 minutes away. But it takes her about an hour because she goes home at rush hour.
贝弗利今天提早离开。她住在斯普林希尔，大约20分钟路程。但她得花大约一小时，因为她赶在高峰时间回家。
Last night when the snow started, she accidentally drove her truck into a ditch. She didn't get hurt, but she banged up her truck badly enough that she couldn't drive it today. So she's leaving early to catch a ride with a coworker.
昨晚雪开始下时，她不小心把卡车开进了沟里。她没受伤，但把卡车撞坏得太厉害，以至于今天没法开车。所以她提早离开去搭同事的顺风车。
That's it. I go home.
就这样。我回家。
She clocks out by sticking her hand in some kind of a scanner, opens the doors to the loading dock, and walks outside.
她通过把手贴在某种扫描仪上打卡下班，打开通往装卸码头的门，走到外面。
So what's the first thing you're going to do when you get home?
那你回家做的第一件事是什么？
The first thing I'll do is put on a pair of jeans and a t-shirt. The second thing is me and my kids go to Walmart or something. She always has to have something on Friday, so that's where I go.
我做的第一件事是穿上一条牛仔裤和一件T恤。第二件事是我和孩子们去沃尔玛之类的地方。她周五总得有什么东西，所以我就去那儿。
Bye.
再见。
Wendy Dorr.
温迪·多尔。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Shawn Wen. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好吧，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、萨拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自肖恩·温。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
A personal note, before This American Life I spent a year reporting at a public elementary school on Chicago's West Side, Washington Irving Elementary. The principal who was at that school when I was there, Madeleine Maraldi, passed away this week. I was an education reporter for years and spent time in dozens of schools. She was the best principal I ever saw. She had incredible savvy about which education programs would work for her school, but like all great principals, she was a great politician. To achieve things that few public schools ever achieve. And of course, she was wonderful with kids. She'll be missed by everybody who had contact with Washington Irving.
一个小注，在《美国生活》之前，我在芝加哥西区的一所公立小学华盛顿欧文小学做了一年的教育报道。我在那儿的时候的校长玛德琳·马拉尔迪本周去世了。我做了多年的教育记者，在几十所学校待过。她是我见过最好的校长。她对什么教育项目适合她的学校有令人难以置信的洞察力，但像所有伟大的校长一样，她是一位伟大的政治家。为了实现很少公立学校能实现的成就。当然，她对待孩子也很棒。每个接触过华盛顿欧文的人都会怀念她。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. This is what he declared this year while standing under the mistletoe.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责。这就是他今年站在槲寄生下发表的声明。
I mean, I got three rules that I live life by. I won't be lied to or about. I won't be stolen from and I will not be laid hands upon.
我是说我有三条我生活的原则。我不会被欺骗。我不会被偷窃，我也绝不会被动手动脚。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。